that what you hate in others is often
what you hate in yourself if we don't
have space for our own capacity for
let's just say violence then when we see
it externally we're going to take an
even stronger stance of bad bad bad
primarily through the kind of work that
we're talking about where Where You Meet
headon In your experience the depth of
complexity that comes with your
humanness and you keep showing yourself
over and over that you're willing to
meet that honestly and work through the
noise and try to parse the soul from the
ego and wisdom from the anxiety when you
do that day after day after day like the
natural byproduct of that is one self-
trust because you know that you're
listening on the deepest level and no
one can tell you otherwise and two
self-respect because you know how hard
it is to do that work and how many
people are basically inviting you to
abandon yourself in service of their
ideas of what you should be doing